It's important to remember that behind the
magic of Asgard are lots and lots of hard-working
people.
And sometimes those hard-working people goof
up or act a little silly.
It's with great pleasure that we present some
of the most hilarious Thor bloopers this side
of the Bifrost.
"The whole thing's a f---ing mess, Taika."
The romantic payoff between leads is one of
the most anticipated parts of any film franchise.
Actors and directors go to great lengths to
shoot and perform the most gratifying scene
possible.
Thor and Jane keep coming up against all kinds
of obstacles to their love, so whenever they're
able to express their affection for each other,
it's a brief respite in the midst of world-altering
chaos.
But it's got to be awkward to kiss your coworkers
sometimes, right?
Especially when you've got your trademark
long blonde Thor locks blowing into her mouth!
Kind of makes you wonder if that's part of
the reason for Thor keeping a short cut later
on in the timeline of the MCU.
"What's that, you mouth full of hair?
C'mon."
This funny little snippet from The Dark World's
gag reel adds some levity to a somewhat fraught
and difficult relationship, and it's nice
to see that even in the midst of something
so intense, Chris Hemsworth and Natalie Portman
can appreciate a little silliness.
It seems Edna Mode from The Incredibles was
right when she insisted that superheroes shouldn't
wear capes.
"Meta Man: express elevator.
Dynaguy: snag on takeoff.
Splashdown: sucked into a vortex.
No capes!"
But Thor is known for his, so he would be
remiss to go without.
Still, it seems to have caused a great deal
of trouble for Hemsworth, who is shown in
several bloopers batting the great swath of
crimson fabric out of his face.
You would think that a weather god who frequently
summons down great winds might consider ditching
the cape and the flowing hair, but he has
an image to uphold.
The problem any fashion-forward hero faces
is knowing that looking really cool often
comes at the expense of being comfortable,
but it wouldn't do to be a god who wears a
windbreaker and tennis shoes.
No one would take him seriously!
Once again, this very relatable problem humanizes
one of the most powerful beings in the universe.
In Norse mythology, the great god Odin has
two raven companions: Hugin and Munin.
These elegant and intelligent birds serve
as Odin's all-seeing eyes, bringing him the
news from Midgard or Earth.
Hugin and Munin don't have a huge role in
the MCU, but it's a nice little nod to Thor's
Norse origins to include them in a scene where
Thor has a heart-to-heart with his father,
Odin.
Of course, the ravens on set are just normal
birds, even if they are more intelligent than
your average city pigeon.
Trained animals aren't always easy to work
with, and ravens in particular are known to
be pretty independent-minded creatures.
Instead of coming off as mystical and mysterious,
these bloopers reveal the birds to be stubborn
and a little hard to work with — typical
avian divas.
Luckily, they seem to have gotten the scene
down eventually, further enveloping the viewer
in the magic of Asgard, but one has to wonder
if the "real" Hugin and Munin ever gave the
Allfather a hard time in the old myths.
Thor and his brother Loki have a really complicated
relationship, which may have something to
do with the fact that Loki is a trickster
god who is never really able to stick to one
side of a fight.
In Thor: The Dark World, audiences are given
a lot of screentime with the two brothers
as they work together to thwart the Dark Elves.
Like any sibling pair, the two squabble incessantly,
even though it's obvious that they care about
each other.
And then, this happens:
"I'm not hitting it, I'm pressing it.
I am pressing it."
"You're not pressing it."
"Yes, I am."
Yup, that's Chris Hemsworth and Tom Hiddleston,
Thor and Loki, breaking into uncontrollable
giggles.
It certainly adds depth to the brotherly love
between their characters — a brotherly love
that we can't help but hope extends to the
actors' off-screen friendship as well.
In Thor: Ragnarok, Thor and Loki are introduced
to the sister they never knew they had, the
terrifying and all-powerful Hela, goddess
of death.
She takes her job very seriously, sowing destruction
and misery wherever she goes.
It is a great blow, then, to see the equally
stunning Cate Blanchett stumble backwards
while unleashing some of that awesome power,
breaking the illusion of Hela's deadly poise.
"F---."
It is humbling to realize that even Blanchett,
one of the most talented and elegant women
in Hollywood, also loses her balance in front
of lots and lots of onlookers when she's trying
so hard to just do her job.
Watching her running around in a motion-capture
suit is also a bit disorienting when we recall
how grandiose Hela's appearance is, but a
death goddess has to do what a death goddess
has to do.
It's important not to take yourself or your
job too seriously, and it seems that no group
knows this better than the cast and crew of
Thor: Ragnarok.
Starting with the eminently witty Jeff Goldblum,
gag reel viewers are graced with several shots
of the actors performing fun little dances,
presumably breaking up some of the hurry-up-and-wait
monotony of a typical day on a movie set.
The whole thing really makes you want to join
in on the fun of filmmaking, and makes you
anticipate watching these goofy actors in
subsequent installments within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
Well, half of them at least.
Sorry… we couldn't resist.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.